la mise en place de l'open innovation et
l'open data dans une entreprise la
thématique d'une rencontre organisée au
ski cube partage des expériences
notamment avec le groupe segula
spécialisée dans l'ingénierie et le
développement de projets industriels
une entreprise basée à trappes est
implantée dans 26 pays
l'open innovation pour nous c'est dire
est une façon à mode de travail qui nous
permet un d'accélérer l'innovation et de
d'augmenter en compétences rapidement
l'innovation c'est aussi une animation
j'irai pour pour stimuler collaborateurs
et recueillir leurs idées donc une
autorisation nous permet aujourd'hui
créer un réseau entre ses salariés ses
clients ou d'autres entreprises le
principe de l'open innovation une
pratique mise en place chez renault
exemple avec les open innovation lab un
travail avec des acteurs externes au
groupe au losange
c'est le fait de dire qu'on va
rassembler autour d'une même table des
acteurs qu'on va plaider qu acteur et
qui vont construire ensemble des des
solutions vous avez edf vous avez plein
de start up et de grosses entreprises
qui se rend compte sur un même sujet là
en l'occurrence et la mobilité et
ensuite la deuxième chose si vous avez
les creative lab c'est plutôt les labels
interne et la cde je dirais de l'open
innovation interne
parmi la trentaine de participants
nabila ali ingénieur en génie civil
à moyen terme il souhaite créer son
entreprise en développant un outils
destinés au btp avec des enjeux autour
de l'open innovation et l'open data
c'est une problématique qui est ressenti
par les territoires que ce soit des
communautés d'agglomération ou des
entreprises
et c'est une question qui a de plus en
plus importante et qui nous touche nous
particulièrement dans le btp prochain
rendez vous au ski cube le mardi 9
octobre à 17h30 pour la welcome party
une soirée pour découvrir les services
offerts par le territoire inscription
obligatoire auprès du ski cube